el juego del amor hola chicos
bienvenidos al juego del amor yo soy su
anfitriona lis y hoy me acompañan dos
guapos solteros bryant y lukas quieren
presentarse claro soy bryant tengo 23
años soy de torrance california soy
actor director y creador y me gusta
jugar al baloncesto boxeo y me encanta
tomar fotos soy lukas soy de redondo
beach california también soy actor
además soy
un aspirante a bombero me gusta acampar
me gusta el ciclismo y me gusta
construir cosas bien puede ser muy útil
el juego de hoy es el tira y afloja
cuando sea su turno forman una fila
frente al soltero que les gusta
[Música]
creo que hay de aquí vamos
apresurémonos
estos son sus equipos tienen cinco
minutos para una cita rápida con cada
lado empezando ahora
en saltaría las preguntas tontas de una
vez comida favor y papas fritas
macarrones con queso ramen japonés a mí
me encantan las papas fritas pero
también un buen possible sushi igual
sushi el mío es el mole es un plato
mexicano el pollo picante me gusta el
folk que es una sopa vietnamita bien
buenas respuestas no me gusta el pescado
crudo entonces no puedo comer sushi
quién o qué es tu inspiración de estilo
cualquier cosa vanguardista me encantan
los pantalones deportivos o algo de
ajuste completo me gusta mucho la moda
parisina que sea elegante con clase
glamour moderno algo que realmente
acentúe mis largas piernas tyler the
creator literalmente lo admiro por su
estilo y todas esas que verdad quién no
yo diría que algo
atrevido incluso algo que sea más
elegante me gusta ahorrar es genial
salvar el planeta todo eso en cuanto a
la cantidad de confianza que tiene
cuando viste cualquier cosa realmente
solo quiero tener la misma energía que
dolly partón encuentres respuesta
inspiración de estilo es mi madre
que su estilo es sumamente genial así
que es ella
este es el final de la ronda de citas
rápidas lukas tienes un equipo preferido
creo que voy a escoger al equipo rojo
quieres añadir una jugadora del
banquillo
los
participantes hay una bandera en el
centro de la cuerda y dos líneas a cada
lado el que cruce la línea primero es el
equipo ganador a mi señal comiencen
y equipo azul ustedes fueron eliminadas
y ese es el equipo que quería ahora
debes conformarse todos son muy fuertes
no es necesario muy bien bienvenidos a
la ronda de citas rápidas bryant tienes
una cita rápida con estas damas durante
10 minutos a mi señal comienzan
qué comportamientos no toleran en un
chico empieza una de las cosas en las
que suelo fijarme es la empatía entiendo
entiendo un mentiroso persistente
cómo tratan a la gente que les rodea si
vamos a un restaurante y trata mal al
mesero entonces él va a tener el mismo
trato hacia mí la negatividad lo que
está dentro se exteriorice está prefiero
que tengan una cama con marco
más cuál es tu idea de una primera cita
me gusta mucho ir de picnic a los
parques y aveces pintar y tomar
fotografías y eso a veces existe la
presión de quién paga porque es si vas a
una cena elegante así que prefiero que
cocinamos juntos en casa comer una
comida ligera me encanta salir a cenar
si terminamos
congeniando supongo que debería decir
salir a los bares después si no es una
experiencia la cena se acaba y puede
salir corriendo de allí con joel ir a
uno de mis restaurantes favoritos así
podré probar lo que te gusta a ti lo que
me gusta a mí y pruebas algo nuevo
definitivamente ir al restaurant primero
pero si va bien a continuación sólo
caminar y mirar cosas genial
[Risas]
ryan sabes qué lado prefieres voy a
escoger
[Música]
y el equipo azul equipo azul quieres
añadir a alguien al equipo que prefieres
si tomaré a los chicos de la derecha
[Risas]
a mi señal
comiencen
[Risas]
el clavo
[Aplausos]
felicidad el equipo rojo
desafortunadamente no tienen ninguna
oportunidad con bryant lo hicieron así
más gracias son las mismas reglas pero
ahora tienen 5 minutos para la cita
rápida y luego al final si prefieres un
bando puede añadir a alguien del
banquillo pero no es necesario
muy bien vamos a preguntar algo distinto
algo que no toleren y luego algo que si
les guste algo permitido como sea no
toleró si son egoístas o no tienen
trabajo me gusta alguien que es muy como
caritativo alguien desinteresado algo
que me gusta es la mentalidad abierta
porque siento que me llevo bien con
muchos tipos de personas diferentes en
el lado opuesto la mentalidad cerrada
alguien que valore al otro y algo que me
gusta es alguien que sabe comunicar sus
sentimientos yo diría que no tolero que
no sepa cómo ser una persona humilde a
veces en una discusión acalorada todos
tenemos que simplemente sentarnos y si
solo tiene su mal comportamiento eso
habla mal de ti sabes a algo que me
gustaría totalmente sería que se hace
espontáneo y eres social yo congeniar y
a muy bien con alguien así algo que no
tolero es a alguien que no tiene tiempo
para otros me gusta alguien que quiere a
otro para hacer
y amigos y también como para ser
romántico tienen ex novios ex novias
que fue lo que terminó con la relación
mi ex novio probablemente está viendo
esto y no me importa rompí con él él era
una persona muy engreída y arrogante la
última persona con quien salí no resultó
porque éramos muy diferentes buscaba
cosas diferentes no funcionó nadie ha
sido mi ex todavía me encanta eso es
increíble y ex y yo nos mudamos a
lugares totalmente diferentes del país
eso nunca funcionará o fue la distancia
no fue literalmente la distancia y
probablemente nunca se resolverá así que
pensé solo es lo tuyo yo haré lo mío
estuve con alguien de forma intermitente
durante dos años creo que los dos no
confiábamos lo suficiente en el otro
como para tomarlo en serio
es un lado que prefieres no sí creo que
voy a ir con el lado azul y te gustaría
sacar a alguien del banquillo para
ayudar al bando azul voy a corregir mis
errores y añadiré a alguien al lado azul
muy bien a quién elegirá creo que no
tengo nombres así que ven tú ven
tú ven aquí
gracias gracias
equipo rojo lo siento mucho pero no
tendrán un audio se aplican las mismas
reglas tiene cinco minutos para tu cita
con estas encantadoras damas unión
volveré
son personas familiares
más o menos solo mi familia inmediata ya
que estoy viviendo en el lado opuesto a
ellos ahora es un poco difícil pero los
veo una vez en la familia es lo primero
siempre vivo para la felicidad de mi
familia estoy muy unida a mi familia mi
familia inmediata es la única en
california así que a ver si nos
mantenemos unidos de acuerdo son ustedes
amigas de signos
no bien
eres amigos de tu eres
no
intentaría ser amigo de tu ex trataría
de estar en buenos términos
ryan tienes un lado que prefieres tengo
un lado que quiero ayudar hagamos que
ayudes al rojo si vamos varias gracias
se aplican las mismas reglas a mi señal
comienzan
vamos a ver
[Risas]
el equipo rojo felicidades eres ahora
una finalista y ahora ustedes van a
tirar cuerda para ver quién es la
próxima finalista ustedes están
compitiendo por el puesto final de
bryant acaban de convertirse en mejores
amigas y lamento hacer esto pero con mi
silbato comienzan
[Risas]
ahora en una finalista bueno abajo buen
trabajo tiene cinco minutos para la cita
rápida con cada lado y si prefieres un
lado al final puedes elegir a alguien
del banco para ayudarlas
volvamos a los ex de acuerdo sé que
hemos tenido un ex así que haremos una
excepción eres amigo de tu ex
si lo eres porque si no lo eres porque
no tengo 12 ex pero mi ex más reciente
lo bloqueé no volvería a hablar con él
un chico con el que salía a veces
hablamos somos amigos y luego hubo otros
realmente ya no hablo con él
definitivamente trato de ser amiga de
ellos a menos que fuera tóxico eso lo
impediría crecería tóxico
una pregunta si me hacen cuestionar mis
valores
siento que eso es tóxico para mí
el equipo rojo a ver qué pasa quien es
fuerte moli
si ves
muy bien felicidades eres una finalista
será la próxima finalista muy bien a mi
señal ustedes competirán por el puesto
final de lucas están listas
es así
sí
y si es vamos vamos
los
ojos
nada cuando termino espera estoy
konfundida puede que tengamos que ver
una repetición porque creo que cruzo
aquí bien veamos la repetición
rápidamente de acuerdo bien lo tenemos y
la ganadora del concurso de tira y
afloja
es tambores por favor
o no
d
muy bien lucas esta es la ronda final
sabes a quién vas a elegir
sí claro estás seguro de esa respuesta
sí sí tienes que tener confianza porque
te voy a dar un premio en efectivo
compartido que puedes usar en tu primera
cita
cuando estás listo muy bien ustedes son
en serio personas sumamente increíbles
solo las conozco hace poco pero creo que
voy a quedarme con
pero en este caso sí
[Aplausos]
bryant esta es la ronda final sabes a
quién vas a elegir creo que sí está
seguro y así porque estoy a punto de
darte un premio en efectivo que vas a
utilizar en tu primera cita
así que escoge bien
w en chicas
veamos
voy a tener que elegir
jana
vamos al banco